This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever walked into a school or workplace and found yourself wondering what the people there think of you? Are they judging you because you're a woman? Why are they staring at me? Or gay? Or an immigrant? I wonder if they'll think I have an accent when I speak.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你是否曾走进一所学校或职场，发现自己忍不住在想：那里的人是怎么看你的？他们是不是因为你是女性而在评判你？为什么他们盯着我看？还是因为你是同性恋？或者是个移民？我在想，我说话时他们会不会觉得我有口音？
Because you have a disability? Because you're poor? Is it because I'm old? Has this affected what you say? Whether you speak and how you act. I hope they don't think I'm boring. Is there something in my teeth? Maybe if I just sit over here and I don't say anything, maybe they won't notice me. On the surface, it would seem like the impressions other people have of us live only inside their minds. It shouldn't affect the way we think or feel or act. But our concerns about other
因为你身体有残疾？因为你穷？是因为我老了吗？这有没有影响到你说的话？你是否开口以及你的举止。我希望他们不觉得我很无聊。我牙齿上有什么东西吗？也许我只要坐在这一言不发，他们可能就不会注意到我了。表面上看，别人对我们的印象似乎只存在于他们自己的脑海里。它不应该影响我们的思考、感受或行为。但我们对他人
people's perceptions have a way of borrowing deep into our minds. Is it because I'm too tall? Do they think I'm fat? Do I even belong here? This week on Hidden Brain, how our worries about the stereotypes people hold of us can shape everything from parent-teacher conferences to police shootings. We all have memories of summers gone by, of long walks and lazy afternoons, relaxing by a pool, vacations with friends and family. Claude Steele has a less pleasant memory of one long ago summer. He was with a group of kids coming home from school. It was in 1950s and they were in Phoenix, a small town just out of Chicago. You know, we were just walking along each of us peeling off as we got closer to our houses.
看法的担忧，却能深深地钻进我们的脑海里。是因为我太高了吗？他们觉得我很胖吗？我真的属于这里吗？本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们对他人刻板印象的担忧如何塑造从家长会到警察枪击事件的一切。我们都有对逝去夏天的记忆，漫步与慵懒的午后，在泳池旁放松，与朋友和家人的假期。克劳德·斯蒂尔对一个遥远的夏天有着不太愉快的记忆。当时他正和一群放学回家的孩子在一起。那是20世纪50年代，他们在菲尼克斯，芝加哥郊外的一个小镇。你知道，我们当时就在路上走着，随着离各自的家越来越近，大家就三三两两地散开。
Claude was six or seven years old. And we're coming home on the last day of school, schools out. The promise of a golden summer stretched out before them. Everyone was talking about how they would spend the coming months of vacation, boasting about their plans. And then one of the older kids said something that seared the moment into Claude's memory. We're talking about what we're going to do, just a sort of gang of kids coming home in the summer and somebody says I'm going to go swimming and somebody else says,
克劳德当时六七岁。我们正值学期最后一天走在回家的路上，放假了。黄金般夏天的期许在他们面前延展开来。每个人都在谈论他们将如何度过即将到来的几个月假期，吹嘘着各自的计划。然后，其中一个大孩子说的话，让那一刻深深地烙印在了克劳德的记忆中。我们在谈论要做什么，就是一群孩子夏天结伴回家，然后有人说我要去游泳，另一个人说，
no you can't go swimming in that. You can't go swimming in a Harvey Park pool unless you go on Wednesday afternoon. That's the only time we're allowed there. Claude didn't fully understand what the older kid meant, but he knew there was an important subtext to the statement. That's the only time we're allowed there. This wasn't just another rule. The library closes at four. The restaurant opens at nine.
不，你不能在那儿游泳。除非你周三下午去，否则你不能去哈维公园泳池游泳。那是我们唯一被允许去的时间。克劳德并不是完全理解那个大孩子的意思，但他知道这句话里有一个重要的潜台词。那是我们唯一被允许去的时间。这不仅仅是又一条规定。图书馆四点关门。餐厅九点开门。
There was something about this particular rule that was frated with meaning. The rule was about them, these particular boys. It wasn't that the pool was only open on Wednesday afternoons. There was something about these kids that meant that they could only use the pool on Wednesday afternoons. Claude listened intently, the way kids do when they realize they have just found a portal into the grown-up world.
这条特定的规定有些意味深长。这条规定是针对他们的，针对这群特定的男孩。并不是说泳池只在周三下午开放。而是关于这些孩子的一些事情意味着他们只能在周三下午使用泳池。克劳德聚精会神地听着，就像孩子们意识到自己刚刚找到了通往成人世界的门户时的那样。
It emerged from somebody else that, no, we can't just go there anytime. You only time, only time black people, only time Negro people, I'm not even sure what term we used in those days. We can only go on Wednesday afternoons. And that was stunning to the group. we used in those days, we can only go on Wednesday afternoons. And that was stunning to the group.
从别人的口中得知，不，我们不能随时去那儿。只有在某个时间，黑人朋友们，只有在黑人朋友们——我甚至不确定我们当年用的是什么词——我们只能在周三下午去。这让大家感到震惊。我们当年用的是什么词，我们只能在周三下午去。这让大家感到震惊。
I just think, first, it was a little mild resistance, but somehow we knew that it was true. It was a fact. I remember just kind of quieting. I could be constructing this memory, but I have a sense of just being puzzled and kind of stopped. Well, what does that mean? What it meant was that on Wednesday afternoons, kids from Phoenix, which was predominantly black, were troop over to the neighboring village of Harvey, which was predominantly white. There would be in Phoenix leading out of Phoenix and going toward the Harvey Park pool on Wednesday
我只觉得，一开始，这只是一种轻微的抗拒，但不知何故，我们知道这是真的。这是一个事实。我只记得自己当时安静了下来。我可能是在美化这段记忆，但我有一种感到困惑并被某种东西卡住的感觉。嗯，这是什么意思？这意味着在周三下午，来自以黑人为主的菲尼克斯的孩子们会成群结队地前往邻近的、以白人为主的哈维村。在周三下午，
afternoons, a kind of long line of black kids with their swimming trunks wrapped in a towel and going to swim in the swimming pool. And you know, you got used to it, but that made you aware of that there was something about you, something about your group that was different and that had some real significance. And I just remember feeling kind of a quiet anger about it, a resentment. A question was forming in Claude's mind. And it was a question that would come to animate the following decades of his life as he became a renowned psychologist. What did these people think of us? And it was a question that would come to animate the following decades of his life as he became
从菲尼克斯通往哈维公园泳池的路上，会排起长长的黑人孩子的队伍，他们的游泳短裤裹在毛巾里，去游泳池游泳。你知道，你习惯了这一切，但这让你意识到，关于你有些事情是不同的，关于你的群体有些事情是不同的，而且这有着某种真正的意义。我只记得当时心里有一种平静的愤怒和怨恨。克劳德的心中正在形成一个疑问。这个问题将在他未来几十年的生活中一直激励着他，因为他后来成为了一名著名的心理学家。这些人是怎么看我们的？这个问题将在他未来几十年的生活中一直激励着他，因为他后来成为了一名著名的心理学家。
a renowned psychologist. What did these people think of us? As the white residents of Harvi looked out their windows on Wednesday afternoons, what did they make of the line of black children walking to the pool? What kind of attitudes did they have? Were they contemptuous and pathetic? indifferent? In time, Claude began to get answers to those questions. It wasn't like someone stopped and told him,
这些人是怎么看我们的？当哈维的白人居民在周三下午望向窗外时，他们对这队走向泳池的黑人儿童作何感想？他们有什么样的态度？他们是轻蔑、可怜，还是漠不关心？渐渐地，克劳德开始得到了这些问题的答案。这不像是有人停下来告诉他：
here's what we think of you. It was communicated like most everything else through how people acted toward him, toward his family. There was a white school and a black school. And the black schools usually had vastly different resources than the white school. You know, you learn that the roller skating ring is only open to African Americans on Thursday nights. I do, I remember that. You can buy clothes in the department stores, but you can't try them on. I remember my brother wanting to be on the baseball team and the baseball coach telling as they were loading themselves onto the bus in front of the YMCA building that not only
这就是我们对你的看法。它就像大多数事情一样，是通过人们对待他和他的家人的方式传递出来的。当时有一所白人学校和一所黑人学校。而且黑人学校的资源通常与白人学校有着天壤之别。你知道的，你了解到轮滑场只对非裔美国人开放，而且是在周四晚上。我确实，我记得这个。你可以在百货公司买衣服，但你不能试穿。我记得我哥哥想加入棒球队，但当他们在基督教青年会大楼前排队上大巴时，棒球队教练却告诉他，不仅
wasn't, he wasn't welcome, he couldn't play, couldn't play on that team. Soon, there were experiences involving our jobs and work. Claude's parents made it clear they expected him and his brother to start earning money. We were not a family with a lot of resources, so it was clear. Our parents also made this abundantly clear, make money. The boys had paper routes. They picked vegetables in a farm. They did lawn detail at the home of a doctor in Harvey. When they were teenagers, maybe 13 or so, Claude and his brother got a tip about work at a golf course.
他不受欢迎，他不能打球，不能加入那支球队。很快，就有了涉及我们工作和就业的经历。克劳德的父母明确表示，他们希望他和哥哥开始赚钱。我们不是一个资源丰富的家庭，所以这一点很清楚。我们的父母也把这一点说得极其明白：赚钱。男孩子们有送报的路线。他们在农场里摘蔬菜。他们在哈维的一位医生家里负责修剪草坪。当他们还是青少年时，大约13岁左右，克劳德和他的哥哥得到了一个关于在高尔夫球场工作的消息。
We heard from some white friends of ours that they'd become caddies. They were caddies, so we thought, let's give it a try. Claudin is brother, decided to take the train out from Phoenix one morning. If you got there early, you got a good number, I remember that. The lower your number, the more likely you'd be called and the more work you'd get. So we went there, I don't know, five, six o'clock in the morning. Claudin is brother, we're pleased to see they were among the first to get to the golf course.
我们从一些白人朋友那里听说他们去当了球童。他们是球童，所以我们想，不妨去试试。克劳德和哥哥决定有一天早上坐火车从菲尼克斯出发。如果你到得早，就能拿到一个好号码，我记得这个。你的号码越靠前，被叫到的可能性就越大，能得到的工作也就越多。所以我们去了那里，我不知道，早上五点、六点钟。克劳德和哥哥很高兴地发现他们是最早到达高尔夫球场的人之一。
One! They were pretty sure they would get Cadi badges. Two! They were excited. Kids came in all day and they were given badges. Number 11. Each time another kid was given a Cadi badge, Claude and his brother thought brother thought okay it'll be our turn next. Number 29
一！他们相当确信自己能拿到球童徽章。二！他们很兴奋。孩子们一整天都在来，他们都拿到了徽章。11号。每当另一个孩子拿到球童徽章时，克劳德和哥哥心想：好吧，下一个该轮到我们了。29号。
they kept overlooking us. And this went on all day, I mean till late afternoon. Number 60. And then after everybody else, I mean dozens and dozens of kids have been given
他们一直在忽视我们。这种情况持续了一整天，我是说一直持续到傍晚。60号。然后在其他所有人都拿到之后——我是说几十个甚至上百个孩子都拿到了
caddy badges. One of the adults came out and looked at us and said, you, using the N word, are still here? When I given you a badge. Claren has brother felt humiliated. It was obvious what the people who ran the golf course thought of them. I do remember so as you know slouching back to the train and getting on it and taking it back home and talking to our parents about it. I have the sense it was a weekend night and we talked about it.
球童徽章之后——其中一个成年人走出来看着我们说：“你们这群（使用N开头的种族歧视词汇）怎么还在这里？”我什么时候给过你们徽章了。克劳德和哥哥感到受到羞辱。经营高尔夫球场的人对他们的看法显而易见。我还记得，正如你所知，我们垂头丧气地走回火车站，上车回家，并和父母谈起这件事。我有种感觉，那是一个周末的晚上，我们讨论了这件事。
The boys were crushed as they shared what had happened. Their parents listened attentively and tried to comfort them. What do you tell teenagers who have experienced naked prejudice? How do you explain what happened? When I think about it, I do think of the warmth of my parents and the support, the intelligence of my parents, to kind of be real and explain this thing as best you could possibly explain it. It's an illness.
男孩们分享了发生的事情后心碎不已。他们的父母专心倾听并试图安慰他们。你该对经历过赤裸裸偏见的青少年说些什么呢？你如何解释发生的事情？当我回想起来，我确实想到了父母的温暖与支持，父母的智慧，他们尽可能真实、尽可能好地向你解释这一切。这是一种病态。
Claude's parents knew all about that illness. Claude's dad was black, his mother was white. They were both active in the civil rights movement. They were married in the 40s, 1942. And in those days, when that happened, the white person essentially was abandoned by her family and moved into the black world, black community. And that definitely is what happened in our family. We had very minimal contact with her family.
克劳德的父母对这种病态深有体会。克劳德的父亲是黑人，他的母亲是白人。他们都积极参与民权运动。他们在40年代结婚，即1942年。在那个年代，当这种事发生时，白人基本上会被她的家人抛弃，然后融入黑人的世界、黑人社区。这绝对就是我们家里发生的事情。我们与她家人的联系微乎其微。
Her parents eventually came and met us. But I was old enough to remember that when that happened. When my grandparents finally came, but we never ever saw any of her siblings or cousins or anything on that side of the family. So that was how it worked. Around the family dinner table, conversations about race, how it worked, what it meant, how to deal with it,
她的父母最终来看望过我们。但我当时已经够大了，记得这件事发生的时候。当我的外祖父母终于来的时候，我们却再也没有见过她那边的任何兄弟姐妹或表亲之类的人。事情就是这样的。在家庭餐桌旁，关于种族的谈话，它是如何运作的，这意味着什么，该如何应对，
were constant. For Claude's dad, who worked as a truck driver, these conversations and the anxiety that provoked them were an ever-present part of his work day. He was constantly worried that as he got older, you know, rather than give him all of the benefits, he might be due, due as his seniority increased, that they might try to fire him, because that's what he and his friends talked about. It's a constant pressure that they might plant something and put something in your coat
是永恒的话题。对克劳德的父亲来说，他是一名卡车司机，这些谈话以及由此引发的焦虑是他工作日中不可或缺的一部分。他经常担心，随着年龄的增长，你知道的，公司可能不会给他应得的所有福利——随着资历增加而应得的福利——而是试图解雇他，因为这是他和朋友们经常谈论的话题。这是一种持续的压力，他们可能会在你的大衣里
and say you tried to steal it and then fire you just at the point when you were going to get some increase in salary or increase in benefit of some sort. And that that happened to black people all the time. And you better be careful. So there's a lot of conversation like that going on. But even as they talk to the kids about the challenges of race, Claude's parents retained
塞进或藏点什么东西，然后说你试图偷窃，接着就在你即将获得某种薪水增长或福利增加的时候把你解雇。这种事在黑人身上经常发生。你最好小心点。所以有很多这样的谈话在进行着。但即便在与孩子们谈论种族带来的挑战时，克劳德的父母依然保持着
a streak of optimism. Experiences like the one at the challenges of race, Claude's parents retained a streak of optimism. Experiences like the one at the golf course were not to be avoided, but to be sought out and confronted. The culture of the family was to resist this illness in society, make them turn you away. And that was probably a byproduct of being in the movement, which a lot of the black community was at that time. And so the idea was, you know, you're a soldier of integration in a sense.
一丝乐观。像在高尔夫球场那样的经历，不是要去逃避，而是要去寻找并直面它们。家庭的文化是去抵抗社会上的这种病态，让他们亲手把你赶走。这可能是参与民权运动的副产品，当时许多黑人社区都是如此。所以当时的理念是，你知道的，从某种意义上说，你是一名融入社会的士兵。
You're out there not letting the world easily take opportunities away from you. I do think they shared, you know, a strong sense that the world really was ours, that we had every right to do what everybody else did, but that there was this evil in the world. There was racism, there was white supremacy in the world. Let us fight passionate men unrelenting, let us for the goal of justice in the world. And things could be changed and that there was a better way to live and the ethos of Martin Luther King is very important in that. I've been reading about the beloved community.
你身处其中，不让这个世界轻易剥夺你的机会。我确实认为他们有着强烈的共同信念，那就是这个世界确实是属于我们的，我们有完全的权利去做其他人所做的事情，但这个世界上存在着这种邪恶。这个世界上存在着种族主义，存在着白人至上主义。让我们充满激情、百折不挠地与之战斗，让我们为了世界上的正义目标而奋斗。事情是可以改变的，并且有一种更好的生活方式，马丁·路德·金的精神在这里非常重要。我一直在阅读关于“受钟爱的社区”的内容。
They were members of such a beloved community. The aftermath of non-violence is the creation of the beloved community. The aftermath of nonviolence is redemption. You know, I grew up as a pretty confident kid. I didn't grow up as a kid feeling hammered into place or subdued. And I think maybe it had us, it came from this framing of things. But Claude was to learn that even though his parents had prepared him to deal with rejection and fear, they had not prepared him for everything the world had in store for him.
他们就是这样一个“受钟爱的社区”的成员。非暴力的后续结果就是创造出“受钟爱的社区”。非暴力的结果就是救赎。你知道的，我成长为一个相当自信的孩子。我成长过程中没有觉得自己被压得抬不起头或受到压制。我想这也许与我们看待事物的方式有关。但克劳德随后了解到，尽管他的父母已经让他准备好应对拒绝和恐惧，但他们并没有为这个世界为他准备好的一切做好准备。
You can confront some fears with righteous indignation, but others borrowed deeper into the mind, and many of them start with that old question. What do these people really think of us? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Claude Steele grew up in a time when black kids could be turned away from public pools, when an employer could openly discriminate against black teenagers and dismiss them with
你可以用正义的愤怒去对抗某些恐惧，但其他的恐惧却深深地钻进了人们的脑海，其中许多恐惧都始于那个古老的问题。这些人到底是怎么看我们的？您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。克劳德·斯蒂尔成长于这样一个时代：黑人孩子会被公共泳池拒之门外，雇主可以公开歧视黑人青少年，并用
a racial epithet. Despite these obstacles, Claude went out to college, graduated, and decided he was going to become a psychologist. He enrolled in graduate school at Ohio State University. And it was here that the question that had been forming in his mind since that summer afternoon when he was six or seven came to the fore again. What did they really think of us? He was one of only a couple of black students in graduate school. There were very few people of color who could serve as role models. Claude was surrounded by smart professors and grad students.
带有种族侮辱性的词汇打发他们。尽管有这些障碍，克劳德还是去读了大学，毕业了，并决定成为一名心理学家。他在俄亥俄州立大学注册攻读研究生。正是在这里，自他六七岁那个夏日午后起一直在他心中酝酿的问题再次浮出水面。他们究竟是怎么看我们的？他是研究生院里仅有的几个黑人学生之一。几乎没有什么有色人种可以作为榜样。克劳德周围都是聪明的教授和研究生。
And although he projected confidence on the outside, he didn't feel it on the inside. That was maybe the time in my life when I felt most kind of shut down, so to speak. I mean, I didn't want to talk in class. I remember being very shy and measuring everything I said and then worrying about what I said afterwards. That's kind of what it felt like. Like I didn't feel unselfconscious. I felt burdened with self-consciousness.
虽然他在外表上表现得很自信，但内心深处却没有这种感觉。那可能是我生命中最让我感到自我封闭的一段时间，可以这么说。我的意思是，我不想在课堂上发言。我记得自己非常害羞，对我说出的每一句话都斟酌再三，然后在事后为自己说的话感到担忧。感觉大概就是这样。就像我无法做到无拘无束、自然坦诚。我感到背负着沉重的自我意识。
It's just overwhelmed by it at some instances. Because the place of graduate school is all about how smart you were and it's exciting new field we were in, social psychology and, you know, how graduate schools get. And I was, you know, sort of exhibit A of a group that didn't seem to belong. So let me jump in for just a second because you said that growing up, you described yourself as being quite confident, despite the things that you encountered growing up in the Chicago area and the racism, the support of your parents and the community, left you being quite a confident kid. So what happened?
在某些情况下简直被它压得喘不过气来。因为研究生院这个地方完全关乎你有多聪明，而且我们身处一个激动人心的全新领域——社会心理学，你知道研究生院都是怎样的。而我呢，可以说是那个“看起来不属于这里的群体”的典型代表。所以请允许我打断一下，因为你刚才说过，在成长过程中，你形容自己相当自信，尽管你在芝加哥地区长大时遇到了种种事情，经历了种族主义，但父母和社区的支持让你成为了一个相当自信的孩子。那么发生了什么？
What was the transition? Why would you not be that same confident kid when you enter graduate school? Yeah, I think my confidence earlier in life was due to a strong conviction that I was on the right side of history, and that my family was on the right side of the history, and that I was doing the right thing, and you know when you were 13 or 14, you kind of take on that mission from the family. So it was all encompassing, and I felt righteous in it, and I felt that, you know, the people who ran the golf course were racist.
转变是什么？为什么当你进入研究生院时，你就不再是那个自信的孩子了？是的，我认为我早年生活的自信源于一种坚定的信念：我站在历史正确的一边，我的家庭站在历史正确的一边，我在做正确的事情。你知道的，当你13、14岁时，你会从家庭中承担起那种使命。所以它是全方位的，我在其中感到自己是正义的，而且我觉得，你知道的，经营高尔夫球场的人是种族主义者。
I felt that they were morally pathetic and misguided and I didn't admire them at all. In graduate school, it just was a very different situation. It was all about how intelligent you were. You know how your group is seen in society. And they're not seen as intelligent enough to belong in an elite graduate school. And you know that at the slightest instant, you could be seen in terms of that, right? And you might not be seen as promising and people might not want to invest in your your development in your future and
我觉得他们在道德上是可悲的、误入歧途的，我一点也不佩服他们。但在研究生院，情况完全不同了。这完全关乎你有多聪明。你知道你的群体在社会上是如何被看待的。他们并不被认为足够聪明，配得上进入一所精英研究生院。而且你知道，在最微小的瞬间，你都可能会以那种视角被看待，对吧？你可能不会被视为有前途的，人们可能不想在你的发展和未来上进行投资，并且
They they might tolerate you out of a sense of well, you know, we should but could they really believe in you? and you had that the worry that that was at stake with every interaction that if if you slipped into your South Side of Chicago dialect boy they would see you it's not belonging here. If you didn't know things in their culture you know that dry wine was better than sweet wine boy you could be seen as not belonging. And so the feel that you were in, the situation that you were in, had all these points that could light up in any minute and give you that feeling,
他们可能会出于“好吧，你知道的，我们应该这样做”的心态来容忍你，但他们真的能相信你吗？你担心每一次互动都面临着这样的风险：如果你不小心滑出了芝加哥南区黑人的方言口音，天哪，他们就会看出你不属于这里。如果你对他们的文化一无所知——比如知道干葡萄酒比甜葡萄酒好——天哪，你就会被视为格格不入。所以，你所处的领域，你所处的环境，有所有这些随时可能被点燃的节点，并给你那种感觉，
that you were going to be seen as not belonging there. So I think that was the nature of that. That was the nature of that. course. You didn't have to guess that someone was being racist to you because they used the N word they kicked you out, they basically made it very plain that their disdain for you was about race. When you were in graduate school, you're not sort of hearing the same thing, people are not calling you the N word presumably. There's no overt, mention, or discussion about race, but it's now all subtext and you're concerned about how people are hearing you and how people are hearing you and how people might think about you. And isn't it interesting that the overt form of racism, your response to that was, you
让你觉得你会被视为不属于那里。所以我想这就是那种性质。这就是那种性质。当然。你不必去猜想别人是否对你有种族歧视，因为他们用了那个N开头的词，把你赶出去，他们基本上把他们对你的蔑视与种族挂钩这件事表露得清清楚楚。当你在研究生院时，你并没有听到同样的事情，人们大概不会对你直呼那个N开头的词。没有公开的提及或关于种族的讨论，但现在一切都成了潜台词，你开始担心别人是如何听你说话的，别人是如何看待你的，以及别人可能会怎样想你。难道不有趣吗？面对公开形式的种族主义，你的反应是
know, righteous indignation and a desire to fight, and your response to sort of the subtler form of the discrimination, was in some ways to shrink? I think you're a great social psychologist. That's really good analysis. That it is the uncertainty of whether you're being seen that way or not, that causes all that pressure and that churn inside your head as to what everything means. Because you don't know what everything means.
正义的愤怒和战斗的渴望，而你对那种更微妙的歧视形式的反应，在某种程度上却是退缩？我认为你是一位伟大的社会心理学家。这真的是很好的分析。正是那种不确定性——不确定自己是否正以那种方式被看待——导致了你脑海中所有的压力和翻腾，让你去琢磨这一切意味着什么。因为你不知道这一切意味着什么。
It's ambiguous. And I'm talking about the graduate school situation. You just, you don't know what everything means. It's ambiguous. And I'm talking about the graduate school situation. You just, you don't know. If you knew that they saw you that way, as you just pointed out, maybe you could adapt, and you could have a sense of a righteousness that would make it easy to put the blame on them, but in an ambiguous situation where you just didn't know, you
这一切很暧昧。我指的是研究生院的情况。你只是，你不知道这一切意味着什么。这一切很暧昧。我指的是研究生院的情况。你只是，你不知道。如果你知道他们就是那样看你的，正如你刚才所指出的，也许你还能适应，你可能会有一种正义感，从而很容易把责任归咎于他们；但在一个你根本不知道的暧昧情境中，你
know that they could see you in terms of that stereotype. It's not promising and not so on and so on. But you don't know that they didn't fax you that way. Maybe they didn't. This was here I am just watching a football game with fellow graduate students and a few faculty and if I talked like I did growing up, what would they think of me? What would that mean? And maybe it would mean, maybe they'd be perfectly fine with it, but you don't know. And you worry that it wouldn't. You worry that they would come to see you as less promising.
知道他们可能会用那种刻板印象来看待你。觉得你没有前途，诸如此类。但你并不知道他们没有那样看待你。也许他们没有。当时的情况是，我只是和同行的研究生以及几位教员一起看一场橄榄球比赛，如果我像小时候那样说话，他们会怎么想我？那意味着什么？也许这意味着，也许他们完全不在乎，但你不知道。而你担心他们会介意。你担心他们会开始认为你没那么有前途。
The stakes were always high. So it's fascinating because you've used the word a couple of times that it was the uncertainty of what was happening that was actually disconcerting. And what's interesting is again, in contrast with the golf course experience, there's no uncertainty in the golf course experience. You know exactly where you stood with the people running the golf course. Whereas with the professors at graduate school, there's uncertainty. And what I'm taking away
风险总是很高的。所以这很迷人，因为你已经好几次用过这个词了，那就是事情的不确定性实际上才让人感到不安。有趣的是，这再次与高尔夫球场的经历形成了鲜明对比，在高尔夫球场的经历中，根本没有不确定性。你非常清楚自己在经营高尔夫球场的人那里处于什么位置。然而在研究生院面对教授时，却存在着不确定性。而我从中领悟到的是
from that is partly, you know, the uncertainty lives in your own mind. It's not just on the outside, it's actually in your own mind. So it's not just that the external world has to give you evidence that there's something that's wrong. Your internal world is now constantly telling you that something is wrong and your internal world is always with you. Yes, that's a good way to put it. I think it does come from the outside role, which is in the sense that you know that everybody around you knows the stereotype about your group, and that they could use it in seeing you and in how they treat you and invest in you, they could.
部分原因在于，你知道的，不确定性存在于你自己的内心。它不仅仅存在于外界，它实际上存在于你自己的内心。所以，这不仅仅是外部世界必须给你证据证明有什么不对劲。你的内在世界现在不断地告诉你有什么不对劲，而且你的内在世界总是与你形影不离。是的，这样说很贴切。我认为它确实源于外部角色，从某种意义上说，你知道你周围的每个人都知道关于你所在群体的刻板印象，而且他们在看待你、对待你以及在你身上投资时，可能会使用这种刻板印象，他们确实会这么做。
But you don't know that that's affecting every particular interaction or a circumstance situation. So it isn't inherently ambiguous situation. And that ambiguity forces a lot of churn on the internal psychological world of where you're kind of trying to interpret things all the time. What did that mean? What did that mean? I shouldn't be, I'm too touchy here. Let's forget about this. No, no, no, he really is. He does not believe in you, man. You are crazy to even think that. And you have to be, you know, you're kind of going back and forth as to what is the situation you're in.
但你并不知道这是否影响了每一次具体的互动或环境局势。所以这本质上是一个充满暧昧的情境。这种暧昧性迫使你的内在心理世界产生大量的翻腾，你一直在试图解读各种情况。那是什么意思？那是什么意思？我不应该这样，我在这里太敏感了。忘掉这个吧。不，不，不，他确实是那样。他根本不相信你，老兄。你甚至会有这种想法简直疯了。而你必须，你知道的，你不得不来回纠结你所处的到底是怎样一种状况。
These fears raised the stakes even during innocuous situations, like when he was hanging out with professors and his fellow students watching TV. The people in the situation were warmly inviting us over to see the football game and just watching a football game. I felt that if anything leaked out as to blackness, that it could lead to a negative judgment. Could I count on the fact that in the America of that time, given the life I had, the America I knew, could I just count on the fact that they'd never think that about me? When it got down to it, they just might not take me as seriously.
这些恐惧甚至在无害的情况下也会拉高风险，比如当他和教授以及同学们一起闲逛看电视时。情境中的人们热情地邀请我们去看橄榄球比赛，大家只是在看一场橄榄球比赛。我当时觉得，如果暴露出任何关于黑人身份的蛛丝马迹，都可能导致负面的评价。我能否指望在那个时代的美国，鉴于我所经历的生活、我所了解的美国，我能否指望他们永远不会那样看待我？归根结底，他们可能就是不会把我当回事。
You would never be there, favorite son, was the worry kind of thing. And you didn't have that kind of opportunity in this situation. So, go back to the third-grade swimming pool situation. You just know how your group is seen. And this is an important situation, but it could be they're just not going to see you that promising. And they never, ever even have much personal awareness of it. They could downgrade you without any awareness that they were doing that. I think that happens all the time.
你永远不会成为他们最喜欢的那个“好孩子”，这就是我担心的那种事情。而你在这类情况下并没有那种机会。所以，回到三年级游泳池的那个场景。你只是知道你的群体是如何被看待的。这是一个重要的情况，但也可能是他们就是觉得你没那么有前途。而且他们甚至可能对此从来没有任何个人意识。他们可能会在完全没有意识到自己在做什么的情况下贬低你。我认为这种事一直在发生。
Claude graduated and became a psychology professor. Over the following 20 years, he studied the nature of alcohol addiction. But his experiences growing up and in graduate school stayed with him. He didn't yet have a conceptual framework to explain them. They just felt like personal experiences. And then, while he was at the University of Michigan, he noticed something about his students that prompted him to make a connection with his own life. African American students at the University of Michigan
克劳德毕业后成为了一名心理学教授。在随后的20年里，他研究了酒精成瘾的本质。但他成长过程以及在研究生院的经历一直伴随着他。他当时还没有一个概念框架来解释这些经历。它们感觉只是一些个人经历。然后，当他在密歇根大学任教时，他注意到学生身上的一些现象，促使他将之与自己的生活联系起来。密歇根大学的非裔美国学生
who had the same SAT scores in prior grades as white students were still getting lower grades at Michigan than other students at Michigan. And I wonder, well, why, how could that be? Here they have the same preparation, the same skill levels as measured by traditional measures and so on. They should be performing the same.
他们在先前的成绩和SAT分数上与白人学生相同，但在密歇根大学获得的成绩仍然比其他密歇根学生要低。我在想，嗯，为什么？这怎么可能？他们拥有相同的准备工作，具备传统指标等所衡量的相同技能水平。他们的表现应该是一样的。
If it's just preparation and ability and so on, and yet they're not. So why is that? And then we found the same thing was true for women in advanced STEM courses. Same preparation, same skills, test scores, but as the work got really difficult, challenging, sort of at the frontier of their skills,
如果这仅仅取决于准备工作和能力之类的话，然而事实并非如此。那为什么会这样呢？后来我们发现，高级STEM（科学、技术、工程、数学）课程中的女性情况也是如此。同样的准备，同样的技能，同样的考试成绩，但当功课变得真正困难、具有挑战性、达到他们技能的边缘时，
you'd see this difference in performance. women not doing quite as well as men. So there was a phenomenon there and we were just trying to figure out what is that, what is causing that under performance. Claude and his colleagues came up with a study. The first step to a solution was to understand the problem. They wanted to see if they could generate underperformance of some students in a laboratory setting. The phenomenon kind of came out of experiments
你就会看到这种表现上的差异。女性的表现不如男性那么好。所以那里存在着一种现象，我们只是在试图弄清楚那是什么，是什么导致了这种表现不佳。克劳德和他的同事们设计了一项研究。解决问题的第一步是理解问题。他们想看看是否能在实验室环境中制造出某些学生表现不佳的现象。这种现象可以说是源于实验，
where we would have, let's take women in math, those were the very first experiments that we did. Women and men who were really good at math, but we would give them a really hard test. A half hour section of a graduate record exam you would take if you were a math major, not the general quantitative section of the exam. So we knew it would cause them frustration, like the advance math courses that they were taking in college.
在实验中我们会让——以数学领域的女性为例，那是我们做的第一批实验。擅长数学的女性和男性，但我们会给他们做一场非常难的测试。如果你是数学专业的话，你需要参加的研究生入学考试中半小时的部分，而不是考试的一般量化部分。所以我们知道这会让他们感到沮丧，就像他们在大学里上的高等数学课程一样。
It would be frustrating. And we had the beginning idea that for women this would be a different experience than for the men. For the men, as they experienced that frustration, they'd worry, Jesus, am I in the right field? Am I as good as Mathes? I thought I was. You know, this is really hard and they have that level of worry. But for women, there'd be an extra worry. In addition to the worry the men have, they'd also worry, is it true what people say about women and their
这会令人沮丧。我们最初的想法是，对女性来说，这与男性的体验会有所不同。对男性来说，当他们经历这种沮丧时，他们会担心：“天哪，我选对专业了吗？我真的像我想的那样擅长数学吗？”你知道的，这真的很难，他们会有这种程度的担忧。但对女性来说，会有一种额外的担忧。除了男性拥有的担忧之外，她们还会担心：人们对女性及其数学能力的看法是真的吗？
math abilities? Am I going to be seen that way and treated that way? So into their minds at some level, conscious, semi-conscious, unconscious, comes this additional worry which takes up some cognitive resources to entertain and you just can't will it out of your mind, it's there. And so our sense was this is going to interfere with their performance. So even though they're just as good at math, they're going to not do as well on this difficult test and sure enough that's what happened.
我会不会被那样看待并被那样对待？所以在某种程度上，在她们的意识中、半意识中、潜意识中，涌现出了这种额外的担忧，它占据了一些认知资源去应对，而你无法将它驱逐出脑海，它就在那里。所以我们的直觉是，这会干扰她们的表现。因此，尽管她们的数学同样很好，但在这次高难度的测试中她们会表现得没那么好，果不其然，事情就是这样发生的。
It was like Claude's experience in grad school. As he worried whether his professors had negative stereotypes about him, that his blackness, leaking out, would make them take him less seriously, these worries imposed a cognitive tax on his performance. He wasn't able to fully focus on the intellectual challenge of graduate school because part of his mind was distracted by the worry that his professors held stereotypes about him. Claude and his colleagues came up with a term for the phenomenon, stereotype threat.
这就像克劳德在研究生院的经历一样。当他担心他的教授是否对他的负面刻板印象、担心他黑人身份的流露会让他们不再那么严肃地对待他时，这些担忧给他的表现强加了一种认知税。他无法完全专注于研究生院的智力挑战，因为他的一部分精力被教授们对他抱有刻板印象的担忧给分散了。克劳德和他的同事们为这种现象起了一个术语：刻板印象威胁（stereotype threat）。
This threat affected the person who was the target of the stereotype. Unwittingly, this could actually make the stereotype appear true. If women underperformed at math because of stereotype threat, someone could look at their results and say, see, we knew it. The researchers had shown they could generate stereotype threat in the lab in the study with men and women taking the tough math test. But to prove they were right, they also wanted to show they could turn off stereotype threat and boost the performance of the students.
这种威胁会影响到作为刻板印象目标的那个人。在不知不觉中，这实际上会使刻板印象显得像真的一样。如果女性因为刻板印象威胁而在数学上表现不佳，有人可能会看着她们的结果说：“看吧，我们早就知道了。”研究人员已经证明，在由男女参与的高难度数学测试研究中，他们可以在实验室里制造出刻板印象威胁。但为了证明他们是对的，他们还希望证明他们能够消除刻板印象威胁并提升学生的表现。
The logic of stereotype threat is demonstrated by showing that if you do the experiment over again or you do different conditions of the experiment, in which you somehow remove the stereotype threat from that math test, then the women should do as well as the men. They are equally skilled. They should do as well as the men without that pressure. If it's that pressure, that is suppressing their performance. So, after a long time, came up with an effective way
刻板印象威胁的逻辑可以通过以下方式来证明：如果你把实验再做一遍，或者对实验设定不同的条件——在这些条件中，你以某种方式清除了那场数学测试中的刻板印象威胁——那么女性的表现应该和男性一样好。她们同样具备技能。在没有那种压力的情况下，她们应该能和男性表现得一样好。如果正是那种压力在压制她们的表现的话。因此，经过长时间的摸索，他们找到了一个有效的方法
of eliminating the stereotype threat. They'd experienced while taking that test. And that way was simply to tell them, look, you may have heard that women don't do as well as men on difficult standardized tests. But that's not true for the test you're taking today. The test you're taking today is one on which women always do as well as
来消除他们在参加该测试时所经历的刻板印象威胁。而那个方法很简单，就是告诉他们：“听着，你们可能听说过女性在困难的标准化测试中的表现不如男性。但对于你们今天参加的测试来说，事实并非如此。你们今天参加的测试是女性总是能和男性一样表现出色的测试。
men. There's no difference here. So now as the women experience, take this test and begin to experience frustration on it, they don't, that extra worry about confirming or being seen to confirm the stereotype about women's having less math ability, that worry's not relevant to this test. We haven't defeated that as a stereotype, but we've made that stereotype about women's math ability irrelevant to interpreting the experience they're having on this test. So they can discard it and just take the test
这里没有任何差异。”所以现在，当女性体验并开始在这项测试中感到沮丧时，她们不会产生那种关于“证实或被视为证实女性数学能力较低这一刻板印象”的额外担忧，这种担忧与这次测试无关。我们并没有将这作为一个刻板印象彻底击碎，但我们让这种关于女性数学能力的刻板印象与解读她们在这次测试中的体验变得无关紧要。所以她们可以将其抛在一边，只需参加测试，
with about the same level of anxiety as the men. And when you do that, the women's performance it, and just take the test with about the same level of anxiety as the men. And when you do that, the women's performance shot up to match that of equally skilled men. I should point you underline equally skilled. It doesn't mean it eliminates a gap between men and women altogether, but it eliminates this mysterious underperformance gap that happens among equally prepared men and women where they do have the same skills, but the women aren't doing as well.
并且焦虑程度与男性大致相同。当你这样做时，女性的表现瞬间飙升，与技能相当的男性不相上下。我应该指出——请在“技能相当”下面画线。这并不意味着它完全消除了男女之间的差距，但它消除了这种神秘的“表现不佳的差距”——这种差距发生在准备工作和技能相同、但女性表现不佳的男女之间。
That gap was entirely eliminated by this getting rid of the stereotype, it's right, pressure. And that was a big day for us, because we saw we had something there. And we could replicate that with almost at the level of, say, you used to say it like a parlor trick. You could get it. And so we had confidence in it. Stereotype threat was like an anchor that the women were dragging behind them as they took the math test. Remove the anchor and the women closed the gap between themselves and equally skilled men. and the women closed the gap between themselves and equally skilled men. Over time, claddenous colleagues conducted more studies to better understand how stereotype threat could affect different groups.
通过摆脱刻板印象威胁带来的压力，这一差距被完全消除了。对我们来说那是伟大的一天，因为我们发现我们成功了。而且我们几乎可以完美复制这一点，就像他们以前说的像个“小把戏”一样。你能做到。所以我们对此充满了信心。刻板印象威胁就像是女性在参加数学测试时拖在身后的一个锚。移开这个锚，女性就缩小了她们与技能相当的男性之间的差距。随着时间的推移，克劳德和同事们进行了更多的研究，以更好地了解刻板印象威胁如何影响不同的群体。
At Stanford University, they looked at the phenomenon in the context of race. We got white and black Stanford students to come into the lab and take again a half-hour section, difficult section, of the graduate record exam. And for half of them, we represented the exam as a measure of intellectual ability. And for the other half, we represented it as just a task that was not a measure of intellectual ability. Our reasoning was that, well, when I'm taking a test, it's a measure of intellectual
在斯坦福大学，他们研究了种族背景下的这种现象。我们找来白人和黑人斯坦福学生进入实验室，再次参加研究生入学考试中半小时的高难度部分。对于其中一半人，我们将考试表述为衡量智力能力的指标；而对于另一半人，我们将它表述为一项与智力能力衡量无关的任务。我们的推理是，嗯，当我在参加一场考试、而它被视为衡量智力
ability, how smart I am. Then that stereotype about my group is relevant. I can't ignore it in interpreting my experience of taking a test. This is a hard test. It's important to me. I'm going to be worried that as I experience frustration on it, that I'm confirming the stereotype or that I'm going to be seen to confirm the stereotype. That all that extra worry, take up cognitive resources, undermines performance, that's what happened. Black students equally skilled to white students didn't do as well
能力以及我有多聪明的指标时，那么关于我所在群体的那个刻板印象就变得相关了。我在解读自己参加考试的经历时无法忽视它。这是一场艰难的考试。它对我来说很重要。我会担心，当我在其中经历挫折时，我正在证实那个刻板印象，或者我会被人看作是在证实那个刻板印象。所有这些额外的担忧占据了认知资源，破坏了表现，事实也的确如此。与白人学生技能相当的黑人学生
on the standardized test. In the other condition we represented the same task, same task it's important to point out, as a task that had nothing to do with intellectual ability. So now as I take the task and experience some frustration on it, it's kind of fun or interesting. Frustration, like if you're solving a puzzle, it's just kind of interesting. And under that condition, black students and white students adjusted for their preparation performed the same.
在标准化测试中的表现没有白人学生好。在另一种条件下，我们将相同的任务——需要指出的是，这是完全相同的任务——表述为一项与智力能力毫无关系的任务。所以现在，当我从事这项任务并经历一些挫折时，它其实挺有趣或挺有意思的。挫折感，就像你在解谜一样，其实挺有意思的。在这种条件下，黑人学生和白人学生在针对其准备情况进行调整后，表现是一样的。
So it was that plank of early studies that gave us some confidence that we had a phenomenon here. It gave me a sense that this captures kind of what I experienced in graduate school and I've experienced it various times continuously throughout my life. That this pressure of being possibly seen through a stereotype in some important part of your life is distracting and upsetting,
正是早期研究的那个基石让我们对我们发现了一种现象充满信心。它让我有一种感觉，这捕捉到了我在研究生院经历的种种，并且在我一生中的各个时期都在持续经历。这种在生活的重要部分中可能通过刻板印象被看待的压力是令人分心和不安的，
and it can interfere with your functioning right there in the immediate situation. And if it continues in that situation, you might say, I don't want to spend my life in this walk of life. I want to go somewhere where I feel just more comfortable. You could imagine, you know, a white guy trying to make it in the NBA or trying to play really elite basketball. But is that, I don't know, it's a long shot, what you're doing.
它会直接干扰你在当前即时情境中的运作。如果这种状况在这种情境中持续下去，你可能会说：“我不想把我的生命耗费在这一行里。我想去一个让我觉得更自在的地方。”你可以想象一下，一个白人家伙试图在NBA立足或者试图打出真正顶级的篮球。但那，我不知道，那希望渺茫，你正在做的事情就是这样。
That kid is in a intense stereotype track situation where any frustration he has could be seen as maybe confirming the stereotypes that whites don't have the same ability in this world. Or maybe he'd be treated like he doesn't have the same ability. Maybe he wouldn't get the same scholarship offers. Maybe he wouldn't get the same encouragement along the way. That people wouldn't invest in him as much because he's a white guy and white guys aren't just dancing and having the same talent in that domain. So that person would be under a very comparable form of stereotype threat that a black kid is going to be under any academic domain or that a woman is going to be under the advanced math domain. So by spelling it out as a stereotype threat, you could see that it's a general phenomenon,
那个孩子正处于一种强烈的刻板印象威胁情境中，他的任何挫折都可能被视为证实了白人在这世界上没有同样能力这一刻板印象。或者他可能会被当作不具备同等能力对待。也许他拿不到同样的奖学金offer。也许他一路走来不会得到同样的鼓励。人们不会对进行那么多投资，因为他是个白人，而白人在那个领域里并不只是在跳舞，也没有同样的才华。所以，这个人所承受的刻板印象威胁，与黑人孩子在任何学术领域或女性在高等数学领域所承受的威胁形式非常相似。因此，通过将其明确表述为刻板印象威胁，你可以看到这是一种普遍现象，
not just something particular to a group. When we come back, the many ways that stereotype threat plays out in the world today. They see all the stuff on television, and murder after murder, after murder, after murder of them, people like them, and they just have to wonder, what do these people think of us? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而不仅仅是某个群体特有的现象。当我们回来时，将探讨刻板印象威胁在当今世界中表现出来的多种方式。他们看到电视上的所有内容，看到谋杀案接连不断地发生，针对他们、针对像他们这样的人的谋杀，他们不得不纳闷，这些人到底是怎么看我们的？欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Claude Steele has spent a quarter century studying the phenomenon of stereotype threat. Drawing on experiments and experiences from his own life, he started to see how the fear that people have of stereotypes about them can affect how they behave. Some people facing stereotype threat just perform worse. Others choose to drop out of their preferred fields, and some find ways to mask their own identity in order to disarm the stereotypes held by others. Claude calls this
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。心理学家克劳德·斯蒂尔花费了四分之一世纪的时间来研究刻板印象威胁这一现象。结合实验以及他自己生活中的经历，他开始发现人们对自身刻板印象的恐惧如何影响他们的行为。一些面对刻板印象威胁的人表现得更差。另一些人选择放弃他们喜欢的领域，还有一些人想方设法掩盖自己的身份，以消除他人对他们的刻板印象。克劳德称之为
Whistling Vivaldi. That is from the autobiography of Brent Staples, who is a columnist with the New York Times now and has a autobiography as parallel time and he describes situation very similar to mine. Going through the in-psychology as a graduate student at the University of Chicago. And coming from a small town, the area is on the south side, walking down the streets of Hyde Park,
吹口哨吹维瓦尔第。这段话出自布伦特·斯泰普斯的自传，他现在是《纽约时报》的专栏作家，有一本自传名为《平行时间》，他在书中描述了一种与我非常相似的情境。作为芝加哥大学的研究生，深入心理学研究。来自一个小镇，那个地区位于南区，走在海德公园的街道上，
big guy dressed like a student, and he could see that he was, he made white people nervous, that, people avoided eye contact, they may have clutched their purses a little bit, walked to the other side of the street, and it threw these things, he could see he was being seen stereotypically, as possibly menacing African-American male in that situation. People were avoiding him. And for a variety of reasons, which he goes into interestingly in that autobiography, he was whistling, and he whistled Beatles tunes in Vivaldi, and when he walked down the streets doing that,
一个身材高大、穿着像学生的家伙，他能看出自己让白人感到紧张，人们会避免眼神接触，他们可能会稍微抓紧钱包，走到街道的另一边，从这些事情中，他能看出自己被刻板印象化了，在这种情况下，可能是一个具有威胁性的非裔美国男性。人们在躲避他。出于各种原因，他在那本自传中以一种有趣的方式进行了深入探讨，他在吹口哨，吹着披头士的曲子和维瓦尔第的音乐，当他吹着口哨走在街上时，
people really responded to him differently. They relaxed, there just wasn't the same avoidance of eye contact, and they clearly saw him not in terms of the stereotype of him being a possibly menacing African-American male, but they probably saw him, oh, he's just a student at the UC. So they could relax and say, hey, how are you doing? To be clear, Claude is not recommending that people facing stereotypes whistle-vivaldi. It's unfair to ask people who are the target of stereotypes
人们对他的反应确实不同了。他们放松了，不再有那种对眼神接触的迴避，他们显然不再把他视为可能具有威胁性的非裔美国非裔男性的刻板印象，而是可能认为，“哦，他只是UC的一个学生”。所以他们可以放松下来，说：“嘿，近来怎么样？”需要明确的是，克劳德并不是建议面对刻板印象的人去吹奏维瓦尔第。要求那些成为刻板印象目标的人去
to compensate for the biases held against them by others. But the story reveals how many of us try to combat stereotype threat. If I was writing a book on the stereotype threat of aging, there would be so many more examples. And here I am getting older, more than getting older, I am older. And the kinds of things people do to deflect being seen as old would be whistling of all the everything from dying one's hair to pulling the gray out of one's eyelashes or eyebrows and presenting one's dressing in ways that you could just enumerate those things. That with every identity, religion, age,
弥补他人对他们的偏见是不公平的。但这个故事揭示了我们当中有多少人试图对抗刻板印象威胁。如果我要写一本关于老龄化刻板印象的书，会有更多的例子。而现在我老了，不仅仅是变老，我是真的老了。人们为了避免被视为老人而做的事情，就像吹口哨一样，从染发到拔掉睫毛或眉毛里的白发，再到以某种方式穿着打扮，你可以把这些事情一一列举出来。对于每一个身份、宗教、年龄、
race, ethnicity, there are negative stereotypes. And when you're in a situation where those stereotypes could be important, if you were seeing that way, they could be important to you, you, people tend to whistle with all the, tend to present themselves. I fit in as an American, might be an immigrant. I don't want those things, those signs from the old country. I want to fit in as an American. I'm going to use, speak Americanese. I'm going to get rid of that old dialect. I'm going to get rid of those styles of dress.
种族、族裔，都存在负面刻板印象。当你处于一种这些刻板印象可能很重要的情境中，如果你被那样看待，它们对你可能会很重要，人们往往会吹起口哨，倾向于表现出：我融入了美国，可能作为一个移民。我不想要那些来自老家的东西，那些痕迹。我想作为美国人融入进来。我要使用、说美式英语。我要摆脱那个旧口音。我要摆脱那种穿衣风格。
I'm going to, and especially in the second and third generation, you're going to see a lot of it. That's the phenomenon that I think is stereotype threat. The more Claude looks at the world, the more examples he sees of stereotype threat. Take for example an ordinary parent teacher conference. Ateacher conference in, let's say, grade school, and the parents are African-American. They're coming to talk to the teacher about their son who's in her class, and the teacher is white because of the stereotypes that exist here and that have come from our history. The African-American couple
我要，尤其是在第二代和第三代中，你会看到很多这样的现象。我认为这就是刻板印象威胁现象。克劳德对世界的观察越深入，他看到的刻板印象威胁的例子就越多。以一次普通的家长会为例。假设是在小学举行的一次教师会，家长是非裔美国人。他们来跟老师谈论她在班上的儿子，而老师是白人，因为这里存在的、源自我们历史的刻板印象。这对非裔美国夫妇
it feels some pressure about stereotypes and they really worry that this school and this teacher is gonna see their child in terms of these stereotypes and maybe them too. And that seeing their child in terms of these stereotypes they're not gonna see his abilities and not want to invest in him and see him as the, again, the favorite son or they just
对刻板印象感到一些压力，他们真的很担心这所学校和这位老师会用这些刻板印象来看待他们的孩子，也许还有他们自己。而且，如果用这些刻板印象来看待他们的孩子，他们就不会看到孩子的才能，不想在孩子身上投资，也不会把孩子看作是那种，再次强调，最受宠爱的儿子，或者他们只是
have a chance to be seen that way because of the stereotypes. So they're on edge as in this conversation. They begin it on edge that their job here is to deflect themselves and their son from being seen in terms of these stereotypes and and they're gonna make this point because this is their opportunity to straighten a school out on this. The white teacher, for her part, she's got an equally powerful form of stereotypes right. She's thinking, Jesus, you know,
因为刻板印象而失去了被那样看待的机会。所以在这场对话中他们如坐针毡。他们一开始就如坐针毡，因为他们在这里的任务是让自己和儿子免于被这些刻板印象所定义，并且他们会提出这一点，因为这是他们纠正学校这种看法的机会。而这位白人老师，就她而言，她也有着同样强大的刻板印象威胁。她在想：“天哪，你知道的，
anything I say here that I intend to be constructive criticism of this young man, is gonna be seen by these parrots as racist. They're going to see me as a racist So there they are on some, you know, Thursday afternoon at four o'clock with the weight of American history Sitting there between them making this of you know, very fraught kind of conversation the same conversation between parents and a teacher in another society would just be ordinary. Everything would be trusted and criticism was appreciated. It would be a very different conversation.
我在这里说的任何我打算对这个年轻人提出建设性批评的话，都会被这些家长视为种族主义。他们会把我视为种族主义者。”所以他们就在某个周四下午四点钟坐在那里，美国历史的重压横亘在他们之间，让这种谈话变得非常令人焦虑。家长和老师之间同样的对话在另一个社会里就会很平常。一切都会被信任，批评也会被感激。那将是一场非常不同的对话。
Maybe between two white people or between two black people, the conversation would be very different. But given our history of this society and the role race is played in it and the kind of stereotypes that have evolved in our society about the groups. This is a very fraught situation. Recent events have illustrated just how fraught the situation can be. Former officer Derek Chauvin is now accused of second-degree murder, which carries a stiffer penalty. Half an hour before a city-wide curfew was supposed to go into effect, police advanced,
也许在两个白人之间或两个黑人之间，对话会非常不同。但鉴于我们这个社会的历史、种族在其中扮演的角色以及社会对各群体演变出的种种刻板印象，这是一个非常令人焦虑的局面。最近发生的事件生动地说明了这种局面可以有多么焦虑。前警官德里克·肖万现在被指控犯有二级谋杀罪，面临更严重的惩罚。在全市范围的宵禁生效前半小时，警察向前推进，
and was seemingly little warning fired tear gas and smoke canisters into the crowd. I've seen the police be more aggressive for 40 people than they were for the thousands of white supremacists that were on the campus. The African-American community is dealing with the stereotype that police anything they do is going to be seen as aggressive and they could be shot through the window of the car. It's a terrifying form of a stereotype threat. And the police are dealing with stereotypes of their own, that this is an oppressive force. It's the thin blue line that protects white supremacy and that they are inherently racist. And their job is to just control this population of people. And anything they say would get them seen that way in terms of that stereotype about them. So it becomes an extremely fraught situation much like the parent teacher conference.
在似乎没有什么警告的情况下，向人群发射了催泪瓦斯和烟雾弹。我看到警察对40个人的攻击性比对校园里成千上万的白人至上主义者的攻击性还要强。非裔美国人社区正在应对这样一种刻板印象：警察对他们做的任何事情都会被视为具有攻击性，他们甚至可能会隔着汽车窗户被枪杀。这是一种可怕的刻板印象威胁。而警察也在应对他们自己的刻板印象，即这是一支压迫性的力量。它是保护白人至上主义的纤细蓝线，他们生来就是种族主义者。他们的工作就是控制这群人。他们说的任何话都会让他们按照关于他们的那种刻板印象被看待。所以这变成了一个极端令人焦虑的局面，很像家长会。
And again, it's American history. The white cop in the white neighborhood is going to be much more relaxed in terms of those kind of pressures. In a different society, with a different history, if we were in the West Indies, it's going to be different. But in America, given our history and the stereotypes about these groups, when you bring them together that way, Derek Shovon and George Floyd on that silly interaction over a possibly counterfeit $20 bill, it is just fraught with this history, shaping the interaction and the tension and the excess
再说一次，这就是美国历史。白人警察在白人社区里，面对那种压力会轻松得多。在一个有着不同历史的不同社会里，如果我们身处西印度群岛，情况就会不同。但在美国，鉴于我们的历史以及对这些群体的刻板印象，当你把他们以那种方式聚集在一起时，德里克·肖万和乔治·弗洛伊德，因为一张可能假冒的20美元钞票而发生的那场愚蠢的互动，充满了这种历史，它塑造了互动、紧张局势以及他们之间的过激行为。
between them. And that I think is, you know, we think we're all past our past. But as I guess Faulkner said, you know, the past isn't even past. It's with us. And these stereotype pressures are one of the ways that the past comes right into our daily lives and shapes our experiences with each other on an ongoing moment-to-moment basis. It isn't far away from any of us, really. The thing that I'm hearing as you're speaking about these interactions, and it's really
我认为这就是，你知道的，我们以为我们都已经走出了过去。但正如福克纳所说，过去甚至都没有过去。它和我们在一起。这些刻板印象的压力正是过去直接进入我们日常生活的方式之一，并以一种持续的、随时随地的方式塑造着我们彼此的体验。它实际上离我们任何人都并不遥远。我听到你谈论这些互动时，那种感觉真的
is poignant. I mean, the description of the parents sitting before the white teacher, the parent teacher, association meeting. And you almost didn't need to finish the thought experiment for us to basically see what was unfolding in that room, as you say on a Thursday afternoon at 4 p.m. There really is sort of a poignancy to it. But there's also, I think, one of the things that's really interesting to me is I think there's a real compassion to this idea of stereotype threat, because it actually asks people to be compassionate, not just to the African-American man of the street, but
非常辛酸。我的意思是，对家长坐在白人老师面前的家长教师协会会议的描述。你甚至不需要把这个思想实验说完，我们基本上就能看到那个房间里正在上演的一切，正如你所说，在一个周四下午4点。这确实有一种辛酸感。但我也认为，最让我感兴趣的一点是，这种关于刻板印象威胁的想法实际上有一种真正的同情心，因为它确实要求人们不仅对街头的非裔美国人抱有同情，而且
also potentially to the white police officer. And I'm wondering, do you ever get pushed back on that? Do people tell you, hang on, Claude, what are you doing? You're basically giving an out to the police officer who is who's just about to shoot or or strangle a black man? There are moments of George Floyd moment, for example, being one where there's just a huge moral convulsion that this is wrong and this society has to fix it. And in that moment, a moment like that, elaborating a psychological and pathic characterization of the police is beside the point, at best. And if it's offered in some way of discouraging that moment, the political significance of the moment,
潜在地也要对白人警察抱有同情。我在想，你曾因此受到过阻挠吗？人们有没有对你说：“等等，克劳德，你在干什么？你基本上是在为那个正要枪杀或勒死黑人的警察开脱？”会有这样的时刻，比如乔治·弗洛伊德事件，那是一个巨大的道德震撼，这大错特错，这个社会必须修复它。而在那种时刻，像这样的时刻，对警察进行心理学和同情式的刻画，往好了说也是无济于事的。如果在某种程度上是为了打消这种时刻、抹杀该时刻的政治意义，
it can be seen as a betrayal of the African-American community. So I don't offer it that way. I offer it as how are we going to go forward? And how is a society are we going to go forward? And it's just as important in that student teacher situation as it is in the policing situation. And that's where empathy is important. We have to, I believe, and maybe this goes all the way back
它可能会被视为对非裔美国人社区的背叛。所以我不是这样提出这个观点的。我是从我们该如何向前迈进的角度来提出的。作为社会，我们该如何向前迈进？这在师生情境中和在警民执法情境中同样重要。这就是同理心重要的地方。我坚信，也许这可以追溯到
to my youth and the tenor of the civil rights movement in that era of a beloved community where we were going to have an integrated world. The aftermath of non-violence is a creation of the beloved community where we were going to have an integrated world. The aftermath of non-violence is the creation of the beloved community. The aftermath of non-violence is redemption. The aftermath of non-violence is reconciliation. The aftermath of non-violence is reconciliation. We were trying, for the first time in our American history,
我的青年时代以及那个时代民权运动的基调——一个我们即将拥有一个整合世界的挚爱社区。非暴力运动的后果是创造了一个我们要建立整合世界的挚爱社区。非暴力运动的后果是创造了挚爱社区。非暴力运动的后果是救赎。非暴力运动的后果是和解。非暴力运动的后果是和解。我们正在美国历史上第一次努力，
to have a genuinely integrated society where everybody had opportunity and support. That's the effort here. That's the American experiment. It's in relation to that American experiment that I think the stereotype concept offers us a way of connecting to each other and trying to find a way forward so that both sides can see what they do to each other, what they mean to each other. And they can use their experience of stereotype to understand the other groups' experience of of stereotypes. Oh yeah, I see. It's just, it isn't just you black people or you women in math complaining about some phantom pressure. This is a pressure I've felt in a different context in a different way, but it's a pressure that I've felt.
建立一个真正整合的社会，让每个人都有机会和支持。这就是这里的努力方向。这就是美国的社会实验。正是在与这一美国实验相关的背景下，我认为刻板印象概念为我们提供了一种连接彼此并寻找前进道路的方法，让双方都能看到他们对彼此做了什么，他们对彼此意味着什么。他们可以利用自己对刻板印象的体验来理解其他群体对刻板印象的体验。“噢，是的，我明白了。这不仅仅是你们黑人或你们学数学的女性在抱怨某种虚幻的压力。这是我在不同的背景下、以不同的方式感受到的压力，但它确实是我感受到的压力。”
I see what you mean. So it gives, I hope, a language to come together and be pragmatic about going forward. I, in recent years, maybe months, I've stressed a lot the need in the situations to build a context of trust that, in this effort to have an integrated society, the first and most important task is to recognize the challenge to trust that our history has bequeathed to us and try to build trust. First, train the police so that they understand the terrible circumstances of ghetto life in America.
“我明白你的意思了。”所以，我希望这能提供一种语言，让大家走到一起，务实地向前迈进。我近年来，也许是最近几个月，多次强调在这些情境中建立信任环境的必要性，即在努力建立整合社会的社会进程中，首要且最重要的任务是认识到我们的历史留给我们的对信任的挑战，并努力建立信任。首先，对警察进行培训，让他们了解美国贫民窟生活的糟糕环境。
The poor schools, the assignment of the worst teachers, the over-disciplinary reactions that happen to black kids in school, the intense policing and sentencing and incarceration rates, the lack of the huge unemployment that besets those communities, destabilization of family life that happens in those communities, the poor access to health care and to good food and so on. And if the police have some sense of what the people in those communities are dealing with, and the people in those communities begin to have some of the, some comparable sense of what the police are dealing with, then they can begin to approach each other a little more empathically. But this polarization into roles that just represent each other as opposing forces, each seeing each other as evil,
糟糕的学校、最差老师的分配、对黑人孩子在学校里发生的过度惩戒反应、高强度的警务、判刑和监禁率、困扰这些社区的大规模失业、这些社区中家庭生活的破坏、获得医疗保健和优质食物的机会匮乏等等。如果警察对那些社区里的人们所面对的困境有了一定的了解，而社区里的人们也开始对警察所面对的困境有某种程度的、相对应的了解，那么他们就可以开始以更多的同理心互相接近。然而，这种两极分化演变成各自代表对方为对立势力的角色，彼此将对方视为邪恶，
is kind of where things stand at this moment in our discourse. And there are things that are accomplished in a huge upheaval of the sort that are very important. I think one of which is that I think white Americans have come to see, it's a, we believe you moment for white Americans they're beginning to see, oh I see, there really are some things
正是目前我们对话中所处的现状。在那种规模的巨大动荡中，有些事情确实取得了非常重要的成果。我认为其中之一就是，白人美国人已经开始看到，对白人美国人来说这是一个“我们相信你”的时刻，他们开始看到，“哦，我明白了，在这个社会里确实有一些事情发生在你身上，
that happen to you in this society because you're black. I see that. That's a big accomplishment of the moment. But in going forward and making our institutions work in our organizations, our schools, we need to have a language for coming together together and I think this is part of it, not all of it of course, but I think it's helpful in getting that set of parents and that teacher to be able to talk to each other and trust each other. Clot Steel is a psychologist at Stanford University.
仅仅因为你是黑人。我看到了。”这是当下取得的一个巨大成就。但在向前迈进、让我们的机构和组织（如我们的学校）发挥作用的过程中，我们需要一种走到一起的语言，我认为这就是其中的一部分，当然不是全部，但我认为这有助于让那对家长和那位老师能够互相交谈并信任对方。克劳德·斯蒂尔是斯坦福大学的心理学家。
Today's show is the first in a two-part series about the paradoxes of knowledge. Next week, if you could hear everything that people really thought about you, would you want to find out? Or is it better to remain in the dark? There are times where I feel as though naivete kept me safe. There are also times where I felt as though I was extremely vulnerable as a result. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick.
今天的节目是关于知识悖论的两部分系列节目的第一集。下周，如果你能听到别人对你真实的全部想法，你会想去了解吗？还是继续蒙在鼓里更好？有时候我觉得天真保护了我的安全。但也有时候我觉得因此而变得极其脆弱。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our former producer, Raina Cohen, who played an important role in building this episode. Thanks also to all our voice actors this week, Julia Druckman, Lila Sales, Vintrin, Brian Shane, Scott Sally, Nancy Van Leidergraf, Jason Hass, and Bailey Lynn. Our Ronsang hero this week is the Society for Personality and Social Psychology. SPSP, as it's known, is an academic organization where many psychologists share their research. At a recent SBSB conference, I heard Claude Steele talk about how the weight of American
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。本周特别感谢我们的前制作人雷娜·科恩，她在打造这一期节目中发挥了重要作用。同样感谢本周所有的配音演员，朱莉娅·德鲁克曼、莉拉·萨尔斯、温特林、布赖恩·沙恩、斯科特·萨利、南希·范·莱德格拉夫、杰森·哈斯和贝利·林。我们本周的幕后英雄是人格与社会心理学协会。简称 SPSP，是一个许多心理学家分享他们研究成果的学术组织。在最近的一次 SPSP 会议上，我听克劳德·斯蒂尔谈到美国历史的重压
history continues to shape our lives. It led to the episode you just heard. For more hidden brain, you can subscribe to our newsletter at news.hiddenbrain.org. If you like today's story and want to help us build more stories like this, please go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如何继续塑造我们的生活。它促成了你刚刚听到的这期节目。欲了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，您可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 订阅我们的简报。如果你喜欢今天的故事，并想帮助我们制作更多类似的故事，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 并点击支持。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。